[Music]
the monsterverse movie godzilla vs kong
which was released last year was quite
convincing at its theatrical release
with worldwide sales of around
450 million use dollars the blockbuster
was at times the most successful movie
during the pandemic now there is news of
the production of the next monster burst
movie from legendary production is
expected to start this year in
queensland australia this was announced
by the australian authorities a few days
ago as the state in the northeast of the
continent is looking forward to a few
hundred additional jobs in the coming
months in fact the title godzilla vs
kong 2 as the monsterverse movie is
currently called is somewhat misleading
as many expect godzilla to play no role
at all in the upcoming movie instead
legendary may focus mainly on kong in
the future as was also hinted at the end
of godzilla vs kong finally this sequel
will reportedly take place inside earth
and feature many different titans
fittingly for this still untitled movie
a return of director adam wingard is
currently being talked about but there's
no official confirmation yet rumors have
also been circulating for some time that
the latest monsterverse movie could be
titled son of kong in reference to son
of kong from 1933 whatever the movie
will be called if filming starts this
year as planned a release in late 2023
or early 2024 can be expected
many know u.s actor christopher lloyd
primarily for his world famous role as
doc brown in the cult classic back to
the future now disney is said to have
secured the services of the 83 year old
for season 3 of the mandalorian the
season is currently still in the middle
of filming after the second season was
already released in october 2020. as
reported by the hollywood reporter lloyd
won't play too big of a role but is
expected to make a special appearance in
the new season after the end of season 2
we hope to see more rousing moments
between grogu and the mandalorian and of
course exciting battles for the
darksaber which is in the possession of
din jardin and should cause a lot of
trouble surely a proper place will be
found for lloyd somewhere in between
perhaps even as a mad scientist when
season 3 of the award-winning series the
mandalorian will be released has not yet
been officially determined but given the
reasonably advanced stage of production
it shouldn't be long now
ask comicbook.com reported this week
fans of avatar can soon look forward to
the first trailer for the second part
this is finally a ray of hope for the
long-awaited sequel after all there were
repeated postponements which ensured
that the movie will now be released on
december 16th 2022 a first official
image was released last december
picturing spider the son of jake and a
thierry otherwise we had to make to do
with a lot of behind the scenes footage
and some concept images which is why the
news about the first trailer has created
corresponding amount of anticipation
disney has not yet announced an official
date but it can be assumed that the
trailer will be released in connection
with the theatrical release of doctor
strange too similar to what happened
with spider-man no way home in terms of
content avatar 2 will primarily explore
the underwater world of pandora and show
how jake and nathery's young family
deals with the tensions between humans
and navi in addition the jump from part
1 to part 2 is supposed to be huge as
actress zoe saldana recently confirmed
in an interview with kevin mccarthy so
far she has only been able to see just
under 20 minutes of the second part but
she was moved to tears as the story will
be much more captivating than that of
the first part we're definitely looking
forward to seeing plenty of returnees
from the first part as well as some new
faces on the upcoming avatar 2 and will
of course keep you posted on more
information you'll probably have best
chances to see the trailer as one of the
first at the theatrical release of
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness which is released may 6 2022 as
soon as disney releases the trailer it
will of course be available in top
quality on our channel
slowly but surely the fast and furious
movie series is coming to an end after
the ninth part was released in theaters
last year only the already announced
10th and 11th parts are still to come
already next year vin diesel and core is
supposed to race through the cinemas
again so it is very convenient that
already the first announcements
regarding the cast are reported the
latest coup is the signing of the 25
year old portuguese daniela melkor who
could already convince with her role as
redcatcher to win the suicide squad in
her first major hollywood movie now
she's playing a role in one of the most
successful franchises of all time though
it's not yet known if on the side of
jason mamow's villain or dumb dorado's
family either way we're looking forward
to more news on the upcoming fast and
furious 10 which is expected to be
released on may 19 2023
we've known about the resident evil
series coming to netflix for almost two
years now as the streaming service now
announced based on three posters this
series will finally be released on july
14 2022 in terms of content the eight
episode series is set in the year 2036
and thus 14 years after the spread of
the disastrous t-virus the focus is on
jade wesker the daughter of the
notorious antagonist albert wesker in
the movie series she tries to fight her
way through a world of bloodthirsty
monsters and other creatures and learn
more about her dubious past with her
father albert and sister billy
so far it is known that john wick
starland's reddick will be seen as
albert wesker also joining the cast our
three actresses ala balinska tamara
smart and adeline rudolph while the
roles are not officially known yet it is
believed that run sweetheart run actress
ella balinsky will take on the lead role
of jade wesker moore is not known at
this point but we can certainly expect a
trailer before the release on july 14
2022
in a few weeks the first episodes of
season 4 of the netflix hit stranger
things will be released a few weeks have
passed since the battle of star court
and for the first time we see the
protagonists not as a team but as
individuals in addition they are dealing
with typical teenage problems in high
school which is why the new supernatural
danger doesn't really come in handy
besides dustin alfie mike lucas and will
there are some new additions that we
don't want to withhold from you among
others nightmare on elm street legend
robert eglin as family murderer victor
creel jaime campbell bauer as nurse
peter ballard and tom bleisha as prison
guard dmitry first images provided the
twitter channel of stranger things
directly with and shows us for the first
time seen images from the finished
series as has been known for some time
the fourth season will be released in
two parts the first episodes will be
released on may 27th 2022 but it will
then continue with the remaining
episodes on july 1st 2022
at the beginning of january scream was
released the first film of the horror
series since the death of ghostface
creator and horror legend wes craven
surprisingly the movie grossed almost
139 million us dollars worldwide and in
view of its financial success just a few
weeks after its theatrical release
ensured that the makers started
production on a sequel immediately very
special honor for the two directors mad
better than the open and tally gillette
after all as was craven's immediate
successes the pressure could hardly be
higher we can also expect a return of
courtney cox's gail weathers in the
upcoming scream six after she was able
to convince again in her role after a
break of almost 11 years in scream the
50 year old actress recently revealed
this in the podcast just for variety
with mark malkin who else may celebrate
a return to the big screen is currently
still unclear the shooting of scream 6
starts this june the us releases then
planned for march 31st 2023
that's it for this week's news don't
forget to check out our channel again
this week not only do we have an
exciting original on the flash
flashpoint but also the new win action
pack trailer for the upcoming michael
bay film ambulance
[Music]